27 years after the sitcom friends
debuted
its stars and creators are far from
broke the much anticipated friends
reunion which aired this week on hbo max
paid monica phoebe rachel chandler joey
and ross
up to 5 million dollars a piece
according to a knowledgeable source
not bad for one night's work but that's
nothing compared to what the stars have
made across the sitcom
for its nearly three decade long run the
wildly popular tv comedy generated
nearly 1.4 billion
dollars in earnings since its broadcast
debut in 1994.
of that forbes estimates the six friends
received nearly 816 million dollars
pre-tax
or roughly 136 million dollars per star
the creative team of david crane marta
kaufman and kevin bright shared pre-cash
earnings
of nearly 550 million dollars
while it aired on nbc from 1994 to 2004
friends drew in an average of 25 million
nightly viewers on its own
but the money didn't pour in right away
for the first four years warner bros
television who licensed the show to nbc
lost money on the sitcom by the fifth
season nbc was intent on keeping friends
in its thursday night lineup
agreeing to cover the costs of
production which over its 10-year
broadcast run
included an estimated 70 million dollars
in producer fees
for bright kaufman and crane and almost
100 million dollars for the stars
who went from making twenty two thousand
five hundred dollars per episode in the
first season
to a million dollars a show in the final
two years
at that time aniston cox and kudrow were
the highest paid actresses in hollywood
the real payoff started when the show
entered syndication to local stations
cable networks and ultimately streaming
services
forbes estimates these deals amounted to
around 4.8 billion dollars for the
production company
creators and cast still share the rerun
spoils
forbes estimates syndication proceeds of
260 million dollars for the cast and 475
million for bright kaufman crane
so they're having the last laugh
you